Trascrizione: Michela Scappaticci
Revisore: marshall8 mathers88
Anche io quando ero bambino sognavo di
essere un supereroe,
di avere dei superpoteri
e di poter volare da un posto all’altro,
di potere guardare
come Superman attraverso i muri,
di poter lanciare le ragnatele,
come diceva Spiderman.
Ma ben presto mi sono reso conto che non
ero un supereroe e non avevo superpoteri
e quindi l’approccio con la vita e con il
mondo che mi trovavo ad affrontare
per portare il mio contributo,
il mio cambiamento
doveva essere un altro.
Avevo una caratteristica particolare.
Sono sempre stato molto curioso, qualunque
cosa che ho affrontato, mi sono
sempre domandato il perché .
E soprattutto quello che volevo cambiare,
il perché no?
Ma andando avanti mi sono confrontato con
la società e il mondo delle imprese.
E tutti coloro i quali
erano le controparti.
L'unica cosa che mi dicevano sempre era
quello che tu vuoi fare è complicato.
Quello che tu vuoi fare è rischioso.
Alimentando la vera opportunità .
Tutto questo non ha fatto niente altro
che ingenerare delle ansie, delle
limitazioni, delle angosce.
In effetti quello che io stavo subendo era
la somministrazione di un veleno, un
veleno che non faceva niente altro
che rendermi immobile.
Però il mio carattere era di altra natura,
di altra pasta.
Io ho cercato un antidoto a questo veleno
che la società e il sistema
ha cercato di iniettare.
E l’ho ritrovato in un verbo semplice
e complesso: il verbo fare.
Declinato in tutte le sue accezioni.
Fare.
Saper fare, saper far fare
processo di delega.
E fare impresa è qualcosa di importante,
di straordinariamente
diciamo responsabile.
Io ho avuto una fortuna enorme nell’avere
l’esempio di mio padre prima e prima
di lui di mio nonno e mi sono ispirato
a loro per capire come fare impresa.
E a quel punto ho verificato che fare
impresa in modo sostenibile rappresentava
un modo di fare responsabilmente sociale
perché nessun imprenditore
alla fine della vita porta con sé
quello che ha fatto.
Nessun imprenditore porta con sé i propri
fatturati, i propri utili, i propri averi.
Non è una gara a diventare i più ricchi
del cimitero per cui bisogna fare per
andare non fare per avere.
E questo si combina con il fare in maniera
sostenibile per l'ambiente.
L’eredità più grande che noi dobbiamo
lasciare a chi viene dopo
perché abbiamo perso il territorio,
il pianeta in uso
dalla generazione che verrà
è di lasciare una eredità
di un territorio,
di un terreno, di un clima
che sia migliore di quello
che noi abbiamo trovato.
Per cui non esiste un’impresa che possa
essere fatta a scapito dell’ambiente.
E poi naturalmente la sostenibilità
economica non esiste un impresa che abbia
un futuro che non sia economicamente
sostenibile.
Bisogna fare profitto, bisogna fare
le cose che servono
e chi come noi lo fa
dal 12:00 d’Italia dove se tutti mi hanno
sempre detto che era complesso farlo in
Italia nel 12:00 mi dicevano
che era impossibile.
Quando io andavo a presentare progetti
di evoluzione dell’amibto logistica
e dei trasporti nel 12:00 d’Italia
mi dicevano che era impossibile
perché il mercato non c’era,
perché non c’era nulla.
L'unica cosa che io ho sempre detto a
tutti che se non c'è nulla vuol dire
che noi possiamo ancora fare tutto.
E dalla parte mia avevo certamente l'età .
Perché ?
Perché essendo un giovane avevo la
possibilità di rimboccarmi le maniche e
di fare. E quindi fare nel 12:00 d’Italia
significa cogliere una grandissima
opportunità e per farlo noi dobbiamo avere
un compimento che è alla base di
tutte le iniziative economiche non.
L'ottimismo.
La speranza che quel veleno di cui vi ho
parlato prima cercava di toglierlo.
Perché è la paura che toglie la speranza
e la paura che toglie la possibilità di
vedere un futuro migliore.
Allora, richiamando una frase di un
grandissimo manager, Sergio Marchionne,
il quale diceva che un uomo può vivere 30
giorni senza mangiare,
tre giorni senza bere,
3 minuti senza respirare,
ma non di nuovo 33 secondi.
Senza la speranza, la speranza che
qualcosa di meglio sia possibile, sia
possibile fare.
Per cui alla fine il ragionamento che io
voglio fare è questo non servono i
superpoteri per cambiare le cose.
Ma se ciascuno di noi, nell’ambito della
propria competenza,
nell’acquisto del proprio spirito
e nella propria iniziativa,
inizia a sperare,
inizia a credere di potere
cambiare le cose.
Tanti piccoli cambiamenti, tante piccole
differenze alla fine faranno
la differenza.
E il super potere che io vi ho parlato
all'inizio, quello che io immaginavo di
potere avere da supereroe non serve.
Su il potere più grande è rappresentato
dalla tenacia, della costanza,
dall'ottimismo, dalla speranza
e dall'assenza di paura.
E quindi coraggio nel fare le cose
che dico, in cui si crede.
Grazie.